Spel das, now we're older, everyone's moved on
But I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel
You're not alone, KappaPogChamp Keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes
I remember typing Dan's game ForeheadSwiftRage, PJSalt and FailFish
Life was easy, spamming all the time TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel
You're not alone, KappaPogChamp Keep a forehead, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes
Still hear his bark in the morning hour he calls me
His doggy emote reminds me of a time far away Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday
Yesterday Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel
You're not alone, PogChamp, KappaPog, BibleThumb, Twitch emotes
Cake, oder?
Egal, das ist jetzt relativ spontan, weil ich hab grad gesehen
Ja, genug Twitch emotes
Ähm, ich hab grad gesehen, dass es eine neue Proxmox Version gibt
Warum kein Subbutton, ja weil Twitch sich noch nicht darum gekümmert hat
Ich glaube Twitch hat besseres zu tun, als den ganzen Tag darauf zu warten, dass der Max endlich seine Bewerbung abschickt
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert, was ich jetzt vor hab, wartet mal
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert, weil
Also wir gucken uns erstmal an, was es hier Neues gibt
Ich hab mir noch gar nichts großartig dazu eingeguckt
Und das letzte Mal, wo ich Proxmox installiert hab, ist irgendwie schon drei Versionen her oder so
Ah, jetzt muss ich die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen
Ha, ich glaube Rocket schreibt auch einfach alle Leute an, die sie in ihrer E-Mail-Liste drin haben
Ich frag gerade, ob ich sie nicht an Stand 2.1 in der Gamescom besuchen will
Wann, wann war ich das letztes Mal auf der Gamescom?
Und ich find so geil, wie die alle die E-Mail in der Gamescom besuchen wollen
Und ich find so geil, wie die alle die E-Mail immer schreiben, also jetzt nicht Rocket in dem Fall
Sondern auch diese ganzen anderen Promotion Dudes
Hey Max, how it's going?
So als würde ich den Typ kennen
Und vor allem als würde der mich kennen
Kennt er uns überhaupt nicht
Außerdem, warum schreibt man jemand, der zwei Videos im Jahr hochlädt?
Die Abos kriegt dafür, oder keine Abos kriegt dafür, weil er nichts hochlädt
Und für den sich eh keiner, warum schreibt er mir überhaupt?
Also ich würd das nicht machen an der näheren Stelle
Ich würd mir denken, ey, der Max da, warum soll ich den mal schreiben?
Egal, es wird ein bisschen komplizierter was wir heute vorhaben
Und zwar
Wieso sollte man zur Gamescom gehen?
Weil man gerne in Schlangen steht vielleicht
Könnt ich mir vorstellen
Also Knäherbär, die Bewerbung ist raus
Und sobald es da ist, kannst du deine 5 Euro loswerden
Also Gamescom hat echt keinen Sinn
Gamescom lohnt sich nur, wenn man gerne in Schlangen steht
Also wir machen mal noch schnell einen Tweet
So, Tweet ist raus
So jetzt kann ich zum eigentlichen Punkt kommen
Was ich eigentlich machen will
Und da müssen wir uns glaube ich auch ein bisschen beeilen
Weil es ist 18.20 wie gesagt
Ich muss um 22 Uhr spätestens pennen, da ich morgen wieder aufstehen kann
Und weil ich hab gesehen, es kam eine neue Proxmox Version raus
Es ist schon 2-3 Versionen her, also schon eine ganze Weile
Wo ich das zuletzt ausprobiert habe
Und das hat mich nicht überzeugt
Das ist ein Open Source Konkurrent für ESX
Allerdings setzen die den Fokus nicht jetzt unbedingt auf Enterprise, HA
Das hat sich für mich bisher nicht so ausgesehen
Sondern eher auf lokale, kleinere Installationen
Dafür haben sie ein paar Sachen dabei, die für alle, die daheim was hausten wollen, ganz praktisch sind
Das letzte Mal, wo ich mir das angeguckt habe, war das wirklich nice
Ich zeige euch mal das Web Interface
Wenn man jetzt keinen eigenen Linux Server installieren wollte für VMs
Oder wenn man ESX nicht wollte
Oder wenn man kein Hyper-V wollte
Oder eben kein KVM von HANA administrieren wollte
Dann hat man hier ein schönes Web Interface gekriegt bei Proxmox
Sieht dann ungefähr so aus, da kann man hier seine unterschiedlichen VMs anlegen
Es erinnert entfernt an das ESX Web Interface
Allerdings viel mehr schwarz-weiß, VM wäre gerne blau und ein bisschen bunter
Er ist mit diesem Datacenter hier und so entfernt an das ESX Web Interface
Das ist alles nicht die neue Oberfläche
So ungefähr sieht das auf dem ESX aus
Und das ist halt komplett kostenlos
Auf Linux Basis bietet KVM und LXC als Virtualisierungstechnik
Heißt ESX-E jetzt nicht VSphere?
Nee, ESX heißt immer noch ESX
Ich dachte generell, dass VSphere eigentlich eher das Management-Gedürz drumherum ist
Und ESX der Hypervisor
Aber ich bin jetzt nicht so der VM-Ware-Experte, was das angeht
So und ich habe mir gedacht, nachdem heute die neue Version erschienen ist, vor ein paar Stunden, das ist noch gar nicht so lange her
Probieren wir das Ganze heute einfach mal aus
Genau, ZFS-Encryption ist dabei
Wir gucken uns gleich mal so kurz an, was sich getan hat
Und danach wird es ein bisschen komplizierter und ich hoffe, das wird funktionieren, weil ich muss das ja irgendwie hier anschließen
Ich hätte die Auswahl
Ich könnte übrigens Leute, ich muss mein Pepega-Bot noch starten, sonst sehe ich eure Fragen nicht
Der Max hat nämlich auch vorhin gefragt, welchen Mikrotik-Router würdest du empfehlen für Heimnetzwerk?
Mit relativ vielen Ports
Schreibt mir das gleich nochmal, wenn ich mein Board geschrieben habe
Wenn ich mein Board gestartet habe, dass ich nicht vergesse
Da muss ich nämlich nachher ein bisschen mehr zu sagen
Was heute ein bisschen kompliziert wird, ist, ich hätte jetzt die Auswahl, man könnte jetzt beispielsweise Rocksmox hier in VM-Ware testen
Aber Virtualisierung in Virtualisierung testen ist nicht so die allerbeste Idee
Ich meine, für einen Chrom-Überblick über das Webinterface und so würde das funktionieren
Nested-Virtualisierung funktioniert mittlerweile eigentlich ganz gut
Aber so wirklich schön ist das glaube ich nur, wenn wir auch die neuen Features testen können
Und das können wir auch auf Hardware-Geschalt testen
Deswegen habe ich mir einen Board rausgesucht, einen Dual-Core-Atom
Celeron, nein Pentium-Silver heißen die Dinger jetzt
Habe ich mir noch einen Board rausgesucht
Noch ein Netzteil rausgekramt
Und hab einen, ich muss mal gucken wie viel RAM da drin ist, ich glaube 8G, 4G
Ich guck mal kurz Leute, wie viel RAM ist da drin
Zum Glück habe ich mittlerweile so viel sammelt Suri um Hardware
Ich erkenne es nicht, wie groß ist der RAM-Riegel
Ah, 8G, also wir haben 8GB RAM, einen Dual-Core, Pentium-Silber
Und das war's
Wir haben einen, ich zeige euch das Board mal, was das für ein Board ist
Das ist so mein, eines der Boards, die ich mir damals geholt habe für mein NAS-Build
Was noch übrig geblieben ist
NGB, das Board hier ist das
Also, das ist auch das was noch ein Parallel-Port in 2019 hat
Wo man sich denkt, the fuck, was ist da los, warum hat es das
Also wir haben einen PC-Express-Slot, den benutzen wir nicht
Ich habe 8GB RAM drin
Und hier haben wir einen M2-Slot
Und in den M2-Slot werde ich jetzt mal zum Test eine Terabyte SSD machen
Ich habe mir eine gekauft für meinen Rechner hier
Und die habe ich aber noch nicht eingebaut, deswegen werden wir die jetzt zum Test testweise mal verwenden
Für unsere Proxbox-Installation
Und dann gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert
Was ein bisschen schwierig werden wird ist
Ich muss irgendwie von der Hardware-Kiste jetzt versuchen über die Elgato-Capture-Card
Muss ich irgendwie versuchen euch das Build weiter zu leiten
Da müssen wir mal gucken wie das Ganze funktioniert
Fluxik, ich habe den letzten Monat fast jeden Tag gestrebt
Aber es ist schön, dass du wieder am Start bist
Genau, also wir gucken uns mal kurz an was die für neue Features haben bei Proxbox 6
Diese ganze ZEV-Geschichte kann ich nicht viel zu sagen
Wir haben auf der Arbeit ein bisschen rumgespielt mit einem ZEV-Cluster
Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht wozu ich das daheim großartig verwenden würde
Das ist ein verteiltes Storage-System
Hast du dir die 10TB WD-RED für dein NAS bei Amazon gekauft?
Du meinst die von gestern? Ja
Die die jetzt aktuell in meinem NAS drin sind, sind das 10TB Seagate Einwolf
Ich weiß, dass ich einfach eine Szene machen kann
Ich muss aber mal gucken ob das hier alles funktioniert mit der Capture-Card
So wie ich es angeschlossen habe
Ich habe ja sogar schon eine extra Szene für Capture-Cards hier
Aber wir müssen mal gucken wie das funktioniert
Also wenn man sich die neuesten Features anguckt zu diesen ZEV-Geschichten kann ich nichts sagen
Corosync 3 ist eigentlich ganz nett, das ist die Cluster
Das ist ein Programm wo man Linux-Systeme mit Clustern kann
ZFS-08, das ist tatsächlich 900 IQ
ZFS-08 ist richtig big brain, da warte ich auch schon drauf
Auf die nächste Ubuntu-Version die da standardmäßig mit dabei hat
Also das ist nicht big brain, das ist schon richtig clever
Die haben nämlich viele coole Sachen dabei
Zum Beispiel haben sie endlich ihren Verschlüsselungs-Patch drin
Damit kann man jetzt quasi mit ZFS direkt die Platten verschlüsseln
Und braucht keinen Lux oder sowas mehr dazwischen
Und das ganze funktioniert sogar mit SSDs, dass da Trim-Support, das Trim irgendwie durchgereicht wird
Also das ist wirklich eine super tolle Geschichte
Und das probieren wir heute mal aus, es supportet auch ZFS auf UEFI-Kisten und auf NVMe-Devices
Das probieren wir nämlich aus, weil deswegen habe ich auch das Board rausgesucht
Das ist eine NVMe-SSD, Anschlussmöglichkeit
Und ich habe eine NVMe-SSD hier gerade da, das bietet sich heute einfach an zu testen
Bevor ich das Ding in meinem Rechner baue
Dann haben wir QEMO 4.0, das ist jetzt eher intern
Wahrscheinlich hat man ein bisschen mehr Hardware zur Auswahl, die man virtualisieren kann
Was haben wir sonst noch schönes?
Ich habe auf Reddit vorher ein schönes Change-Log gelesen dazu, ehrlich gesagt
Genau, es gibt eine neue LXC-Version, also sprich das Ding kann Voll-Virtualisierung und Container-Virtualisierung
Und Gedöns, wir müssen es einfach mal ausprobieren
Würdest du eher den 3700X oder den 3900X CPU nehmen?
Für Game-Stream und Videos machen
Der 3900X hat mehr Kerne, da würde ich den 3900X nehmen
Vor allem wenn es um Games plus Streamen geht und du CPU encoden willst, dann sind mehr Kerne auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt
So, und jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken wie wir das machen
Als erstes müssen wir uns den Kram mal downloaden
ISO-Installer, oh BitTorrent
Da ist die Filesharing-Anzeige gleich raus
Den besten Ruf hat es ja nicht, obwohl es ja eigentlich nur ein Übertragungs-Protokoll ist, was eigentlich an sich keinen schlechten Ruf haben dürfte
Download, ISO, jawoll
Ok, wo ist mein USB-Stick? Ich brauche meinen USB-Stick
Moment, Moment, Stopp, Stopp Leute, warum lade ich den Mist überhaupt unter Windows runter, das ist ja ein kompletter Fail
Da muss ich meinen Linux-VM runterladen, da kann ich das Zeug wenigstens gleich ordentlich flaschen
Ich flasche auch USB-Sticks
Mir fällt es immer schwer den korrekten, immer die korrekten Begriffe für zu nehmen, bei mir wird alles geflasht
Mikro-SD-Karten, USB-Sticks, Festplatten wird alles geflasht
Auch weil man Festplatten eigentlich überhaupt nicht flaschen kann
Aber ich meine, wen juckt es?
Ok, während der Kram downloadet und das Stream hoffentlich dabei nicht rumrockelt
Muss ich mal kurz hier den USB-Stick crabben
Komm her, USB-Stick, huge USB-Stick, da ist er
Und bei Anschließen und dann flaschen wir das Ganze
Und danach teste ich mal, ob der Mist funktioniert mit, ähm
Mit Capture-Card und allem
Werden wir gleich sehen
Erstmal USB-Stick
Ja, ich habe gedacht, bevor ich das jetzt irgendwie noch eine Stunde vorbereite, alles
Und dann haben wir keine Zeit mehr, fangen wir einfach direkt mit dem Stream an und beeilen uns ein bisschen
Also ran an die VM
USB-Stick sollte erkannt worden sein, hoffe ich mal
Äh
Da ist der USB-Stick
16G wird reichen, denke ich mal, wie groß ist das ISO?
700, äh 742 MB
Ok, ähm
Etcher
Heutzutage flasht man ja, braucht man ja eine komplette Elektronen und
Heutzutage braucht man ja einen kompletten Browser, der in einem eigenen Fenster läuft, nur um eine
Nur um einen USB-Stick zu flaschen
Weil, weil es geht
Ähm, Downloads
Oxmox ISO
Auf den USB-Stick, der irgendwie USB, ähm, Ubuntu Server heißt, aber ist ok, Flash
Man kann es ja 50 Diskette nehmen, easy, nein, ZIP, ZIP Diskette nehme ich, ZIP Drive
Da reichen dann nur 7 Stück
Kann man inzwischen Oxmox ohne CD installieren?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab ewig kein Oxmox mehr verwendet
Es ist schon
Ich sag mal Jahre her, wo ich das letzte Mal Oxmox verwendet habe
Ich hab, ich hab bin eigentlich übelster Noob, was das angeht, also
Wenn der Installer sackt, werden wir es wahrscheinlich nicht auf die Reihe kriegen
Gucken wir mal, es wird schon, wird schon funktionieren
Ähm, so, wenn das Ding geflasht ist, muss ich erst mal gucken, dass das mit der Capture-Card funktioniert
Ich schlöpsel euch jetzt nämlich gleich einfach mal dran an das Board
Und schalte um auf die Capture-Card und wir gucken, ob man was sieht
Ja, ich installiere das auch, auch über USB, das wird auf jeden Fall funktionieren
Verwendest du da eigentlich für eine VM-Software auf Windows?
Für was meinst du jetzt?
Ach so, was ich eigentlich für eine VM-Workstation
Das ist eine VM-Workstation
So, der USB-Stick ist geflasht
Jetzt probiere ich das mal schnell mit der Capture-Card aus
Ich stöpsel euch mal dran und wir gucken, ob was passiert
Moment, ich muss das erst mal umschalten
Scene 2, dann machen wir hier unseren Yo-Dog, machen wir weg
Ähm, Browser-View machen wir weg, ich weiß, ihr seht gar nichts, Elgato ist an
Und jetzt machen wir hier oben in die Ecke noch eine Display-Capture
Die machen wir aber so dann
Ähm, ach so, den Chat brauchen wir noch, oder?
Q-Chat brauchen wir noch
Q-Chat, ähm
Da muss ich euch mal kurz ausmachen, dass ich den Chat darüber bringen kann
Da muss man nämlich Secret-Wolves kopieren
Und die will ich euch nicht zeigen
Eats
So, jetzt haben wir hier Chat, wie groß ist vielleicht der Chat?
Jaja, Leaked, Jebaited wird hier höchstens
Wie mach ich das jetzt kleiner?
Moment, wir machen das Display-Capture nochmal aus, da seht ihr nichts
Noch Browser-Capture an, jetzt machen wir 400x400 oder was man da so braucht
Jetzt ist besser, oder?
Wie groß ist denn der Chat bei dem anderen?
Ja, das ist ungefähr genauso groß
Das lassen wir so, oder? Wir machen vielleicht noch ein Stückchen weiter
Thicc-Chat
Und Display-Capture, so, jetzt haben wir es, perfekt, oder?
Was ich hier leider nicht drinne habe, sind Donations und Gedöns
Kannst du mal was mit Shell sortieren, please? Pipe-Sort
Alternativ Pipe-Sort N, wenn es numerisch sein soll
Es ist eigentlich Eats IF
Du kannst einfach ein Beispiel reinposten, dann sag ich dir, wie es funktioniert
Subscriptions, ja wie gesagt, meine Bewerbung ist raus
So, jetzt schließe ich mal die Capture-Card an
Dann hoffen wir das Scheiß funktioniert
So
Habe ich bei dem Elgato Ding jetzt irgendwas getan?
Es sollte eigentlich
So ein Elgato Ding angezeigt werden
Probieren wir es mal so
Da war bei mir der Ton
Ok, wir schalten mal kurz um auf das hier
Und wir probieren es mal hier mit
Und gucken, ob das Board an sich funktioniert
Ok, ähm
Ja, ich mache mal das Board an, würde ich sagen, und dann gucken wir, was passiert
Aja, ja
Geht was?
Passiert da was?
Oh, oh, oh, fuck
Ist das Netzteil laut
Ist das Netzteil laut, das pumpt sich ja hier ein ab
Ok, jetzt machen wir die Elgato Software zu und gucken, ob es im OBS funktioniert
Ich entferne einfach mal das Elgato Ding hier nochmal drin
Remove
Game Capture
Ne, ach Quatsch, nicht Game Capture
Das Ding heißt nur Game Capture
Video Capture Device ist es
Ey
Da guck an
Da guck an, man erkennt was
Pock
Huge Pock
Ok, wir müssen jetzt mal checken, ob die Auflösung irgendwie halbwegs passt
Ähm, Resolution, wie macht man das? Gar nicht, das macht alles automatisch, hä?
Handficker Video, HD, Input, blim, blim, blim
HD
Input Device
PC
Ok, wir probieren einfach mal aus, ob das funktioniert jetzt
Also Leute, was, wollen wir mal hier, ne, wisst ihr was, es ist doch eigentlich viel besser, wenn wir das machen
Und wir machen es mit der Game Capture HD Software, machen wir es Fullscreen, oder?
Das ist doch wahrscheinlich viel besser
Oh fuck, muss ich das erstmal da wieder löschen
Profi Streamer
Doch, ich glaube es ist besser, wenn wir das so lassen und machen die Game Capture hier auf
Oh fuck
Hab ich das jetzt geschrottet?
Flip
Ich hab ne Idee was wir machen
Wir ziehen den USB-Stacker einfach nochmal raus
Äh, macht das jetzt was? Ah ne, Connect to Host
Ha, haha
Ok, auf, mach hinne, Capture Card
One moment please
Warum ist das schwarz? Und warum kackt es ab?
Ok
Ich werd, ich werd die mal kurz hier aus OBS removeen
Was hat das denn jetzt für Schmerzen, ey
Äh
Alter, was jetzt
Ok, ich mach die, ich mach die Capture Card nochmal raus
Weiß was, ein Akt, ey